now the last film I'm going to talk to
you about today is from one of the
biggest series of films at the studio
and these are some of my all-time
favorites and in my opinion they are
unlike any other franchise out there in
terms of adventure comedy drama and
their ability to transport viewers to
another world
they are singular in tone and scope and
spectacle arriving in July of 2017
pirates of the caribbean dead men tell
no tales it is an incredible return to
the world of Captain Jack Sparrow with
the one and only Johnny Depp back in one
of the most iconic film roles a 21st
century this time we see the resilient
resourceful seemingly indestructible but
as usual down on his luck Jack come face
to face with a terrifying new adversary
in Captain Salazar this unearthly foe is
played by the incomparable Javier Bardem
we will also of course see jack square
off against his old friend of me Captain
Barbossa with the return of the great
Geoffrey Rush and we have some very
exciting new additions to the cast
including a young man named Henry played
by Brenton Thwaites and a brilliant
young scientist Karina played by Kaya
Scodelario who were seeking a treasure
that has the power to unlock an eternal
curse and there's another character in
this tale and in this franchise that we
think the audience particularly loved
seeing jack interact with character we
haven't seen in a little while
we've asked me to come back and for d23
I want to officially announce that will
Turner played by a railroad
we wanted to welcome out the one and
only brand-new Disney Legend Johnny Depp
Captain Jack Sparrow
hello
ladies and gentlemen Jack Sparrow d23
you